it's 5 26 on your Monday morning what's
driving you crazy how about another
complete shutdown of Northbound I-15 for
the Tropicana project but believe it or
not it really should not be a big deal
starting at nine tonight scheduled to
run until 5 tomorrow morning Northbound
drivers you'll be diverted off to those
Lanes next to the freeway at Russell
Road but then right back onto the main
Lanes before you get to Tropicana really
nothing to get hung up on in fact that's
the reason for the closure they're
hanging another one of the new 10
overhead signs designed to help you get
through the lane squeezes and closers
and yes whatever crashes may happen in
fact one of the bigger traffic impacts
of that project is the upcoming
construction of a new half interchange
at Harmon like the one on the 95 at
Elkhorn in the far Northwest Valley this
is where that's going to happen stay
tuned buckle up drive carefully please
put down that phone join the driving you
crazy conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com